- Good afternoon.
Thank you for your patience,
for waiting patiently as
we made our way up here.
My name is Eddie Mandhry,
Director for Africa and the
Middle East at Yale University.
And Your Excellency, honorable ministers,
permanent secretaries, (indistinct),
members of the delegation,
ladies and gentlemen,
I extend a heartfelt Yale
University welcome today.
We're absolutely delighted
to have you join us,
for this African Leaders Forum lecture.
Each year, on the sidelines
of the United Nations General Assembly.
We have a meeting, or convening
of Heads of State at Yale,
so that they can deliver,
some kind of vision for their nation,
and their transformation and
development of their economies.
This will be the 7th such lecture at Yale.
And first following the start
of the COVID-19 pandemic.
This lecture is presented
as part of the Yale Africa Initiative,
a university-wide effort,
launched by President Salovey,
at his inauguration in 2013.
Aimed at refocusing our
engagements across Africa,
elevating discourse on Africa at Yale,
attracting some of the
best and brightest students
from across the continent,
among them current
Botswana's cabinet member,
Kefentse Mzwilina.
And one other critical
dimension of the initiative,
is our efforts to foster
bi-directional collaboration
in areas of mutual interest,
with partners across the continent.
President Masisi's visit to Yale,
is particularly significant
because moments ago,
His Excellency signed a
memorandum of understanding,
between Yale and the
Government of Botswana,
for new partnership that
will serve as a launchpad,
for mutually beneficial
exchanges and cooperation
between both sides on
research and training,
focused on various aspects of
natural resource management.
His Excellency Mokwgweetsi
Masisi will speak on his vision
for transitioning Botswana
to a knowledge-based economy.
His lecture will be followed by Q&A,
moderated Q&A conversation here with me,
and an opportunity for him
to respond to questions,
from some of you in the audience.
Please mute your mobile devices.
And before His Excellence, it comes up,
it's my pleasure to invite to the podium,
a member of our own community,
a PhD candidate at Yale
School of the Environment,
who has spent a fair
amount of time in Botswana.
Working with our
counterparts at local NGOs,
and the Okavango Research Institute
at the University of Botswana.
She's passionate about,
the nexus between livestock and wildlife,
and how humans, livestock, and
wildlife impact each other.
Most recently, she worked
in the Boteti West
sub-district in Botswana.
Focused on the interactions between
the Central Kalahari Game Reserve,
and the Makadikadi National Park. (laughs)
I hope I got that right?
- [President Masisi] Close.
- Close. (laughs)
Kaggie Orrick, I welcome
you to this stage.
(applauding)
- (speaking in foreign language)
(speaking in foreign language)
- [President Masisi] Oh, thank you.
- Very honored to be welcoming
His Excellency to Yale.
His Excellency, President
Mokgweetsi Masisi,
began his career in the education sector.
From 1989 to 2004,
he had a variety of
positions in public sector,
including national coordinator
for Social Studies Education in Botswana.
Education officer in the United Nations,
and HIV/AIDS, prevention researcher
with the Tropical Disease Research Center.
In the 2000s, politics came
knocking, and heated the call.
In 2009, he successfully
contested the election
to serve as a member of
parliament for Moshupa.
Subsequently, he held various
cabinet level appointments
from public administration,
to education and skills development.
In 2014, he was endorsed as
the vice president of Botswana,
and was given responsibility
overseeing national programs
spanning from poverty eradication,
economic diversification,
and job creation.
In July of 2015,
President Masisi became the chairperson
of the ruling Botswana Democratic Party,
and retain that post through 2017.
In 2018, President Masisi was elected
as the fifth president of Botswana.
In the October of 2019 President
Masisi was reappointed.
And as for a five-year term,
after the Botswana Democratic Party
won the general elections,
by garnering the majority
in the national assembly.
President Masisi holds
a master's of science
in social studies education
and instructional systems designed
from Florida State University.
And a graduate degree in
economics and and social policy
from Manchester University,
where he was a distinguished
achieving scholar.
It is my absolute distinct
pleasure and honor
to be welcoming His Excellency,
President Mokgweetsi Masisi,
to the podium,
to deliver his Yale African
Leaders Forum lecture,
entitled, "Botswana's Vision
for a Knowledge-Based Economy."
Thank you. (applauding)
- Thank you.
Thank you very much.
(speaking foreign language).
President Peter Salovey, in absentia,
President of Yale University,
distinguished members of the faculty,
the Director for Africa
Initiative, the Yale community,
my distinguished fellow
Motswana, from Boteti West.
Honorable Minister Kwape,
and senior government
officials from Botswana,
ladies and gentlemen, a very good evening.
It is a distinct honor,
for me to have been
invited to this occasion,
to address you, on an important subject,
regarding Botswana's perspective,
on a knowledge-based economy.
This honor, does not
only extend to myself,
but it also extends to Botswana,
the people of Botswana.
My acceptance of the invitation
from the Yale community
is a living testament, to
this special relationship,
that has been established
and continues to flourish,
between the Republic of
Botswana and Yale University.
I suppose, a living testimony
of the Yale Africa Initiative.
Yale University and its living
commitment to excellence,
remains a source of
inspiration to all of us,
who hold similar dreams to a path,
to a sustainable and prosperous future.
I have no doubt, that the
seeds of collaboration,
that we have already
sown, will fully blossom,
for the mutual benefit of our friendship.
It is in this regard, that
I wish to share with you,
where Botswana is headed,
as we March towards a
knowledge-based economy.
Such an ambitious and noble initiative,
is also an invitation
to the Yale community,
to join us, and help us, in this journey.
At the independence of Botswana in 1966,
Botswana was one of the
poorest countries in the world.
Despite a small population,
subsistence agriculture was
the main source of livelihood,
for the people of Botswana.
There was some observers,
who even questioned the state of our mind,
for taking the bold step
of seeking independence.
However, with innate determination,
our forefathers were not deterred,
from going ahead with the project.
The country dependent
heavily on foreign aid
for both its recurrent
and development budget.
However, Botswana's
economic fortunes changed,
in the early 1970s, following
the discovery of diamonds,
which became the main state
of our economy to this day.
Our founding fathers who
managed our resources,
with a high degree of frugality,
invested heavily in the construction
of schools, roads, hospitals, airports,
as well as the provision
of basic social services,
which has taken the form of free,
and affordable education amongst others,
to enhance a better standard of living.
Botswana's natural
resources have also been,
in the form of our natural
endowments, namely,
mineral deposits, flora and
fauna, the land, and the people.
The primary focus, in regard to these,
has been the people, as the owners,
beneficiaries, and the driving force,
behind the expectation of such resources.
The country graduated
to high middle income,
but as the economy grew,
the population multiplied
at a faster pace than
economic development.
Even though, we have invested
a lot in human capital,
the productive capacity has decreased,
and we need to re-tool
and re-skill our people,
in order to make them relevant,
to the dictates of the global markets.
In our national vision,
we have set ourselves amongst others,
the target of being a high
income country by the year 2036.
The vision further in joins us to strive,
to become a knowledge-based economy.
Distinguished guests,
knowledge and technology,
are in the heart of economic
development for any country.
And knowledge economy,
as we may all be aware,
is largely driven by three main factors,
being human capital, relevant
and effective policies,
and the requisite information
and communication
technology infrastructure.
Essentially, a knowledge economy,
is realized when most income
and economic activity,
is driven by content and knowledge,
rather than other physical resources.
At best, such content and knowledge
should be domestically
contrived and patented.
As a country, we have prioritized
in our current national
development plan for policies,
that will drive economic development,
towards attainment of
sustainable economic development.
These are; promotion of export led growth,
ensuring more efficient
government spending and financing,
building human capital,
and the provision of
appropriate infrastructure.
The tourism sector, has
been a long time accounted
for the majority of Botswana services.
Though, others exist such
as financial services,
administration and
other business services.
Information technology services,
and the range of professional services.
Many of these require knowledge-based...
Many of these require
knowledge-based specialized skills,
and for us as a country, we
need to support the development
by strengthening intellectual
property framework.
Ladies and gentlemen,
getting the educational basics is a right,
is a prerequisite, for equipping Botswana
with the skills to
successfully transition,
to a knowledge-based economy.
Educating our people and
sustaining productive human capital
has always been at the core
of our economic development
since independence.
Some of the most specialized skills,
that we need to create and manage,
the fourth industrial
revolution, FIR technologies,
such as coding, genetics,
data science and analytics,
well in due course,
needs to be central to school
and college curriculum.
This is why this financial year,
the government has committed about 24%
of the overall national
budget to education.
This translates to 15.730 billion Pula,
or about 1,000,000,573 U.S. dollars,
making it the largest share
in our national budget.
The proposed budget will
cater for the development
and sourcing of e-content for schools,
training teachers, and school
managers in basic ICT skills,
and the use of technology
on teaching and learning.
The allocation is geared towards providing
appropriate education and training,
to students, so that upon
completion of their studies,
they could become active
players in the transition
of the country to a
knowledge-based economy.
This will include
improving the foundations
of learning and the
quality of our education,
and the scope of pre-primary education.
At the secondary level,
there will be focused on
improving outcomes for learners
in terms of maths and science.
Areas where performance has
been below expectations.
Furthermore, the speed
of change in technology
and production, obligates
that learning be a lifelong process.
And that today's learners will
need to have the capacity,
to really equip themselves with skills,
perhaps several times, during
their working lifetimes.
Hence, the importance of softer skills,
such as flexibility and initiative.
This will be important,
not just for individuals,
but also for the economy as a whole.
One of the challenges of FIR,
is that emerging technologies
such as automation,
artificial intelligence,
genetic engineering, and
blockchain, may displace jobs,
as production becomes
more technology intensive
and capital intensive.
Distinguished guests in
view of the global trends
towards a knowledge economy,
we have embarked on an ambitious project,
to broaden the national digital ecosystem,
through the national digital
transformation strategy,
commonly known as SmartSpot,
to deliver a smart, sustainable
society for our country.
The strategy, aims to
transform the public sector,
to efficiently provide services,
to citizens and businesses.
The SmartSpot strategy also
seeks to increase mobile network
and mobile broadband coverage.
And to provide internet connectivity
to government facilities,
and strategic locations
across the country,
have been identified
for connection to ensure the most impact.
As reflected in my
government's reset agenda,
which has prioritized five areas
in our development trajectory.
Digitization has been identified,
as one of the priority areas
that has the immense potential
to unlock and enable high
productivity among our people,
the majority of whom are youth.
Trending knowledge-based services,
require upgraded connectivity,
with high quality, dependable,
low cost bandwidth,
stimulated through the widespread rollers
of e-government services,
and ensuring effective operation,
of the national ICT broadband,
and lower local area networks.
To this end,
part of the second largest
share of by development budgets
will cater for information, communication,
technology projects,
being the government
data network upgrading,
national broadband networks,
government data center,
and local access network.
My government continues to look
for strategic development partners,
who can assist the country to capitalize,
on the fourth industrial
revolution technologies,
to advance our objective
of connecting our people
for the betterment of their lives.
I want to highlight the fact
that Botswana subscribes
to an open market economy,
and government's role is
only facilitative in nature.
Therefore, I want to assure you
that we remain committed to governance,
that facilitates the private sector
as an engine of economic growth.
The creator of wealth,
and the much needed employment
opportunities for our people.
This in a nutshell, is
a synopsis of our vision
for a transformative process,
towards a knowledge-based economy.
I will once again, enjoying
the Yale community,
and other willing partners,
to accompany us on the promising journey.
I thank you for your attention.
(applauding)
- Your Excellency kindly take a seat.
- Yeah.
- This one.
- Thank you very much, Mr. President,
for really engaging lecture,
centered around your vision
for knowledge-based economy in Botswana.
I'd like to begin with a small anecdote.
I heard that you earlier had
an engagement with Bloomberg.
And in 1965, there was a film.
There's a book published by Ian Fleming,
now widely read and even adapted
to a movie in 1971 James Bond.
Film by the same names,
"Diamonds Are Forever."
Mr. President rumor has it.
You're in New York,
in the possession of the
world's third largest diamond,
(laughs)
one found earlier this year,
1,175 carrots at a mine
Karowe in Botswana,
is this true?
And if so, can you
officially put the debate
to rest, are diamonds forever?
(laughs)
- You know, thanks for the question.
Let me begin with the facts.
Has the diamond been discovered
that's the third largest in the world?
True.
Was it discovered at Karowe Mine,
a Karowe Mine owned by Lucara
Diamond, a Canadian company?
True.
Was it in Boteti West? (laughs)
Is it about 1,175 carats?
True.
Is it rough?
Is it a diamond?
It's a diamond. (laughs)
Were we in possession of it this morning,
or holding it on launching?
True. (laughing)
Do we own it? (laughs)
No.
It is owned by Lucara,
and I'm really proud to introduce somebody
who is very close associated with it.
One of the world's leading lights,
in the diamond trade and industry,
and technology and management Oded.
- Oh, Oded.
- Welcome. (applauding)
From HB Antwerp.
He's one of the partners with Lucara
who are going to be managing that diamond.
- Yes.
- And doing what they think is best
to give it additional value.
And what are we waiting for is government.
We want them to succeed the most,
get the most money out of it,
because then we just
get some tax. (laughs)
We get royalty.
- Yeah.
- And we urge them to
go out and find more,
because they're going underground.
- All right,
well, you haven't--
- And yes,
diamonds are forever.(laughs)
- Okay, well you have
settled the debate to then.
Well, thank you for outlining
kind of all the dimensions
of this Karowe diamond that was founded.
I mean, so we convened
in an interesting time of
unprecedented disruption
in our global community.
The pandemic has caused a
lot of pain, anguish, death,
loss of life, and economic
struggle across the world.
How are the people of Botswana doing?
And how are you fairing?
- The COVID-19 pandemic
has been devastating.
It has had a deleterious
effect on our economy,
on our livelihoods and people.
But we are resilient people,
and so we've got to face
up to it, and confront it.
And the best confrontation,
when you're a third
world developing country,
without the power of the by chemical,
or by medical response,
is to use people power.
And use your intellect to manage it,
on the base of the advice
we get from scientists.
And I'm glad this country, though,
our university has given us
some of the best brains to do that.
Who is here with us today,
Professor Mosepele Mosepele,
trained in Harvard.
- Oh.
- He is our deputy coordinator
for COVID-19, (clapping)
and infectious disease specialist.
And so they us on what to do,
and we follow that advice.
And we regulate on that advice.
We communicate on that advice.
He's on national TV every
week is a household name.
And he basically dispenses,
this advice in language
that people understand, and can relate to,
and he practices medicine,
and teachers, young doctors
at the university teaching hospital.
And so, we have responded
in ways that we can best,
but it's affected us.
We've had a loss of life, we loss of jobs,
loss of opportunity, loss of market.
And we've seen our bank balances,
and debit accounts depleted,
as we buy the necessary PPE
and other interventions, such as vaccines.
Even though, we paid so many vaccines
that have not yet arrived yet.
- Thank you for outlining that.
And we also would like to note that,
we do welcome people who've
been to the university up north
that won't be named as part
of our community. (laughs)
Not much Crimson around,
but that's okay. (laughs)
But we appreciate how difficult
and challenging this time must be,
for you and the people of Botswana.
And we hope that as vaccines
become more accessible,
and that there is some light
at the end of the tunnel.
Many leaders, some leaders
who have come to speak
at Yale in the past,
have sometimes pointed to
the miracle of Singapore.
Lee Kuan Yew model of
transformation and development
as being one of the pathways
they aspire to taking,
to transform our continent.
I'm curious about your sentiments
on several African countries,
steering to look eastwards to partners,
and for opportunities
for trade and commerce,
technology transfer and so on.
China obviously, comes to mind as well.
So I'd be curious about
your international engagement strategy,
and your engagement in the East.
- Well, broadly speaking, we
have very open foreign policy.
We are non-aligned,
because it's in our best
interest not to be aligned.
It's in our best interest,
not to be dealing with problems
that are not going to help us develop.
And so, what's on this
foreign policy is premised,
on protecting and growing
Botswana's interests first.
We have friends, both in
the East and the West,
from whom we derive a lot of benefits.
We exchange views and we share values,
but we do have differences.
And those differences we
manage diplomatically,
but, those things are
essential for our development,
and growth, we negotiate for,
and we take what's best
for us at the time.
And both have a lot to offer.
So, we're in the lucky
position of shopping,(laughs)
and making you compete.
And we pick what we think
is the most competitive.
We're not always right.
And so we learned from those experiences.
So we do shop in the West,
we've shopped in the West much more
than we shopped in the East,
but we also do shop in the East,
for both ideas and content.
And so, it's a (indistinct) to say that,
we do work very harmoniously with China,
very harmoniously with the
United States and others.
As for the model of development,
yes, Singapore is done exceedingly well,
but, Singapore is not Botswana,
and Botswana is Singapore.
For one, the land mass is different,
their weather patterns are different.
We in Botswana have a big budget,
that is dedicated to
a wildlife department.
Something Singapore
could never have, right.
In Botswana, we have to deal
with human wildlife conflict.
And a lot of human wildlife
conflict these days,
is to do with elephants.
We happen to be the home
of the highest number of elephants
in the wild in the world.
We've looked after them on
your behalf, right.(laughs)
And when I say your
behalf, I mean the world.
- On behalf of humanity.
- Yes, it's a resource that we all share,
but we do get into conflict with them.
And you've got to manage that conflict,
without endangering the people,
without endangering the wildlife.
And so, it's not exactly
a transferable model,
as one would wish.
We are a democratic system,
an open liberal democratic system.
We've had elections every five years,
and it is my fervent and
hope and determination,
at least while, I'm in charge
that they will have
elections every five years.
Free, open, transparent,
and fair elections.
And it is the winner
who will assume power.
So if we go to the elections
and I lose, I lose,
I go home and I won't turn
back, I won't want to come back.
And so, you can't exactly impose
a model from a cities nation states,
on a developing state like Botswana.
- No, thank you.
Thank you for pointing out this.
The fact that the context
is very different,
and it's important, and
there are various nuances,
that are unique to your nation
and various needs and dynamics,
that make it necessary
for a policy that's
responsive to those needs.
We'd like to open to a few
questions from the audience.
I know we started a little bit late,
so please raise your hand
and press the button.
When the light turns green,
you'll be able to speak
into the microphone,
kindly introduce yourself,
and keep it brief, because
we don't have much time.
Thank you, go ahead, yeah.
- [Participant] With the transition
to the knowledge-based
economy for Botswana,
what is the Botswanian government doing
to encourage entrepreneurship
among Botswanians?
- One more question, gentlemen
at the bike in the gray suit,
the gray jacket, yep.
- [James] Thank Your excellency,
James Mwangi I'm a Yale
old fellow over here.
You mentioned the role that
Botswana is playing as a steward
and indeed many countries
on the continent playing
as a steward of the world's
natural biodiversity and bounty.
Coming after the COVID discussions,
we'll be heading into COP26,
and the discussion around climate.
What is your view, on what is the...
How is Botswana thinking
about its positioning,
around COP26?
And what do you think is
Africa's overall role,
in the fight against
climate change globally?
- (indistinct).
All right, thank you very much.
What's Botswana government doing
to encourage entrepreneurship in Botswana.
We're providing a lot of
education and opportunity.
Legislative space is created,
so that there are some reservations.
We tussled back and forth about
the prudence of reservations
and the lack of it.
So we're very careful in its use,
but when we have infant
industries develop,
and we have a nice, an
entrepreneurial culture emerge,
we attempt to protect that.
We provide training,
we provide mentorship,
we provide procurement categories
for certain things to be bought
from those entrepreneurs,
but it's just never enough.
It's never enough because,
we need such a small scale
entrepreneurs to grow,
and get to the next stage,
until they become fully
fledged business persons.
So, it's an ongoing challenge.
And we do provide training
right after university.
It's the relevance of that
would, which is important.
James Mwangi, you asked
if Botswana being a steward
of our national resources.
What are we thinking about the upcoming
environmental conference in
November in Edinburgh is it?
- Glasgow--
- Glasgow, sorry,
in Scotland.
We're signatories to the Paris Accord one,
we are very determined to make
sure that we play our part,
in contribute into the
management of climate change.
We're extremely worried, by United States,
whose impact is significant
with respect to issues of climate change.
Delighted that America is back
as a party to the Paris Agreement.
You can use your hand a
little bit. (applauding)
- Oh yeah.
- But you need to catch up, (laughs)
you need to make up for the lost time.
You really need to, because,
you're such a big
economy and a big player.
We need to harness the green energy space.
And we may be just as guilty because,
we apparently have some of
the best sun opportunity.
And we have a integrated
resource plan that we've approved
and we're tilting to go green.
We say this and we want this,
in a situation where we had discovered
huge deposits of coal.
I mean, more than 200 billion tons.
- My goodness.
- Can you imagine?
- Yeah.
- And so, we're tussling
and grappling with what
we do with all that.
There were others who were
wanting to exploit it,
but increasingly as you know,
financial institutions are not be willing
to fund that beyond 2030.
And so, if anything started now,
it really would make a
return on investment.
So, so we are deeply committed.
We want other countries in Africa,
at least those we associated with,
in the national economy management space,
to go together with us on that,
but it needs huge investment.
And a lot of investment is R&D.
And so we look to learning,
leading researchers,
institutions such as Yale,
to help us at least with the capacitation,
to be able to help us else in on that.
- Well, they don't envy
you having to deal with
that decision about the
coal deposits, (laughs)
but last I checked diamonds
come from carbon and coal.
So this could bode well for the future
of Botswana in some way.
- Yeah. (giggles)
- We'll take a few more questions.
One here, this gentleman,
and a lot of hand back there,
orange shirt next, yes.
- [Desmond] My name is
Desmond and I have a question
regarding trans boundary relationship
between Botswana and her neighbors.
And how you intend, or your approach,
towards ensuring that these initiative,
that you're undertaking,
is also transient and it moves
into this other, your counterpart,
and that you become an influential point
where all the other
countries can look around you
and begin to copy what you're doing.
Is there initiative to do that?
Or are you just focusing
more on the protection needs
than just Botswana itself as a country?
- Yes.
- [Abraham] Thank you Your Excellency,
my name is Abraham Kaita
and I'm from Liberia.
A student in Yale College.
First of all, I wanted to say thank you
to the people of Botswana
for being the shining city on a hill
for prioritizing democracy in Africa.
My question has to do with,
what is your government doing
to promote women empowerment,
and women involved in
democratic processes?
Oh, yes, we celebrate Botswana
for having a sustained
decades of democratic rule.
We have Seretse Khama, Ketumile Masire,
and all the four presidents before you.
But what is the government doing
to ensure that women are inclusive
in the governing process of Botswana?
Thank you.
- Just one more, all right.
- Hi my name is Abby Coke
I'm from the School of Public Health.
Thank you so much for
coming to speak to us today.
And I wanted to ask,
what does cooperation look like
within the continent for
you, and for Botswana,
under this lens of
knowledge-based economy?
- Sorry, could you ask again?
What is?
- (indistinct).
- Can you say it again, pleas.
- Oh, what does cooperation look like
on the continent of Africa
under this lens of
knowledge-based economy?
- Take one more, yeah.
- One more.
- Let's do it, Udu.
- [Udu] Yeah, my name
is Ugu Udu from Nigeria.
So I was, I'm really curious to know,
just like the last person said,
Botswana is one of the shining lights
on democracy in the continent.
But if you look at current reports,
Freedom House Economic Intelligence,
decline of democracy in the
continent is really worrying.
Increasingly a lot of
countries in Africa are going
from democracy to hybrid
democracy and plain dictatorships.
And the African Union has
one of his commitments,
the protection of
democracy in the continent,
and serious resistance to
undemocratic change of power.
I just wanted to know the
Council of the Head of States,
what are you guys doing at this point,
to address this decline?
And what lessons, can
we pick from Botswana?
What has worked in Botswana
that's not working now in
the other parts of Africa,
that we're having this terrible,
terrible loss to democracy.
We have about three, four
coup on the continent,
between last year and this year.
So what was your take on this?
- Thank you.
- Udu, thank you so much.(laughs)
Let me begin with the...
Where do we start now?
Was it Abraham Kaita?
Were you the first one?
- No,
he's the first one.
- No, Desmond.
- Desmond.
- I think it was Desmond, right?
- Yes.
- Botswana and her neighbors?
Yes, how we influencing one another?
We are part of a region,
both in the economic
space, through the SACU,
the oldest customs union in
the world, began in 1910.
That's between Botswana,
Eswatini, Lesotho,
Namibia and South Africa.
And so, we cooperate.
It's not an equitable system,
as many unions are not.
And so, we were trying very
hard to make it work better,
as we all develop.
We also part of SADCC,
that's a social economic
and political organization.
And it's got a big
number of member states.
Where in, we also have a very
political and focused organ,
which I just happily chaired for a year.
And I had to over to President Ramaphosa.
The Organ Politics Defense
and Security Cooperation.
It is that instrument, more
than any other within SADCC,
that is used to influence one another
in the political space, between countries,
in the spirit of promoting
political cooperation,
promote defense cooperation,
security cooperation.
And a battery of values
for holding elections, for
instance, is generated.
A system of monitoring for
elections is generated,
a system of presidential
influencing is in...
And I could just let you know,
I wish I had my phone here to take it out.
I was messaging up in between
ourselves and President Lungu
as the elections were unfolding.
And part of that messaging
was to she to ask him,
"Hey, let's be with it.
I mean, it doesn't look
like you've made it.
So please accept the results."
It's not easy to say that to
another head of state because,
we often restricted by the
considerations of sovereignty.
But we as colleagues,
you'll find that when
you're president. (laughs)
You talk to one another
sometimes very frankly,
particularly when you
develop a friendship.
And so, we've developed that within SADCC.
And it doesn't always work, right.
I must admit it doesn't always work,
because you can only do
and say things to a point.
And it's only when it gets really bad,
that you, you would raise alarm.
There's also the...
And this is a continental wide one.
It gets to part of what
Udu, I think is asking.
It gets a little more complicated
when it gets to the
African Union and bigger.
Many of African countries,
including those in the south,
attained the independence
through struggle, right.
They fought for liberation.
And when you're a liberation hero,
that seems to cling on, and
it seems to blind some people
into not seeing on pointing
out, not accepting,
some things that may be going wrong
that may be happening.
And there's a lot of solidarity that
has being part of the
narrative for a very long time.
But that's slowly changing
with the generations,
that come on.
But, outright condemnation,
and is often viewed very
negatively and not effective.
It's best to engage as countries relate.
So yes, I would accept what you say Udu,
democracy, it would
seem is on the decline.
And it's very worrying.
There are a number of
coups have taken place.
There was a time when
the AU abhorred coups,
but we still do...
But they still do happen.
So, there's a lot more than
a thing needs to be done,
in terms of capacitating and training,
those who would manage
their affairs in Africa,
there's not enough of it being done.
Abraham Kaita, we thank you...
So you thank us for democracy in Africa,
but what are we doing in Botswana
to promote women empowerment in politics?
Gosh, I wish the women would
have answered that. (laughs)
We do everything we can
to try and encourage them.
And I speak on behalf
of even the opposition,
the political parties in
Botswana, we do very badly.
Many women have said very openly,
they find politics in
Botswana unattractive,
it's vicious and nasty.
And so, there's also the aspect of costs.
Over time, men have had great opportunity
to generate income more
than women generally.
But what we have done as a government,
the executive level, is
promoted a lot of women.
Probably 50% of my permanent
secretaries are women.
At least, all the permanent secretaries,
from the permanent
secretary to the president,
the deputy permanent
and all the permanent
secretaries in the presidency,
three ministries of the
presidency in Botswana, are women.
And one of them is here,
permanent secretary from ministry
of international affairs.
(applauding)
There're women.
But you can have a conversation with her,
why she doesn't skip over and
contest elections. (laughs)
And others as my chief of protocol,
that's a woman, deputy
permanent secretary level,
you wanna raise your hand.
(applauding)
You can ask her why they
don't get into politics,
but we've had some very
successful women politicians.
There are very few.
The real in party has the most
number of women in parliament
and the only women in parliament
from the ruling party,
the other parties unfortunately,
well, I shouldn't say, unfortunately,
we don't want them to increase
in number so much.(laughs)
So don't have any in parliament.
So, we will continue to
encourage our women folk
at the political party level.
There are a number of models
because we are gonna be
reviewing our constitution,
that some people are postulating.
A past having a reservation system,
some people don't like it at all.
A quota system, some don't like it at all,
but it's not really for me to say,
the nation will speak,
and they will decide what they want to do.
Because it's disturbing,
when you have more than
50% of your population,
not represented at the leadership level.
It's very worrying,
it's almost like a single
parent headed household,
and the parent I men.
And when they go be a
drinking, it's a problem.
Yeah. (laughs)
Abby Coke, I think it is.
What does corporation look like
in knowledge-based economy?
Particularly in the region,
we have training exchanges,
intellectual capacity exchanges.
We have our lawyers, patent lawyers.
We could be offering trading
in one university in the region
and sharing that with others.
That is be the basis for the future.
So it's really about building
the ecology for that.
Our customs clear in systems,
our payment systems and
platforms, we need...
So there are a lot of work to be done,
in terms of providing solutions
and new systems of exchange.
And that's where the
excitement is because,
you can generate so many
things that do not occur,
that just I'm not there.
And you can develop a new economy.
So, I look to our young people
to really take us to the moon on this.
And we will pay them to help us do that.
I think those are the
ones that were asked.
- [Eddie] Yes, yes, no, I
think that's, unfortunately,
we might have just time
for one more question
and then we wrap up.
So this is a tough one, wow. (giggles)
Okay, gentlemen, right here.
- [Nadeem] Hello, my name is Nadeem.
Thank you very much for coming
and for the great lecture.
My question is with respect
to energy and energy access
with particular regard to
rural communities in Botswana.
As you talk about a
knowledge-based economy,
increased technology access, e-education,
these things seem inherently
tied to energy access
and reliable energy access.
And I'm wondering what your
administration is doing,
and perhaps, who you're partnering with,
to improve energy access in the country,
to enable the knowledge based economy
that you speak of to take root, thank you.
- It's a great question, great question.
A, we're looking for more partners, right?
But we're looking for partners
that are creative and innovative.
And you know why, because,
some of the places that
do not have energy,
or access to energy,
are in far, remote, difficult to reach,
lowly populated places.
But with this enormity of sunlight,
we think, the solution
would be solar, off grid.
We have our integrated resource plan.
And by the way, access to energy,
and reliable energy is
quite high in Botswana now.
Rural electrification is pretty high,
but the rate at which
settlements are growing,
sometimes outstrips the supply capacity
within a particular locality.
But with the integrated resource plan,
it would allow for those
who generate energy,
excess energy from a solar
plant, to sell it to the grid.
And the beautiful thing in
Southern Africa is that,
we have an integrated exchange system
for selling energy to other countries.
So you can actually trade,
and sell your energy to Zambia,
to Mozambique, and Lesotho,
wherever there is a deficit.
And we plan to be able to export energy
within the next three years.
Because we've floated tenders
to generate 100 megawatts of energy
from solar in additional, to what we have.
And we will be licensing,
independent power producers,
as they come and go.
Rooftop solar systems are coming up.
And so, any other new partners
who come with new solutions, come see us.
- [Eddie] Excellent.
- We're a great country to
be in by the way.(laughs)
I mean, just...
We love visitors, we
take good care of you.
We let you in and out.
We let your money in and
out as you want, (laughs)
in any currency, no exchange controls.
And if you have excess money,
you can just go down the street
and buy some diamonds and
take them home.(laughs)
- [Eddie] Excellent.
Well, I am certain that there
will be many in this room
and outside this will take
you up on your invitation,
to build stronger cooperation
and ties between us
and the people of Botswana.
Especially in your ambition
to develop a knowledge-based economy.
You've covered a lot of ground
in your lecture and conversation today.
Gender equity, climate
change, renewable energy,
natural resource management,
adding value in the supply
chain for people, education.
But also importantly, your
vision for a non-aligned approach
to your international engagement,
to fulfill the priorities
and the needs of the people
of Botswana through cooperation.
And so, it is in that spirit,
that we're delighted to
have you here on our campus,
to set the stage and
articulate that vision.
So, we're out of time
for the lecture portion of this session,
but, we would ask you
that you please remain seated as we exit.
And there will be a
following reception upstairs,
but before you leave Mr. President,
there's the obligatory, (laughs)
Yale cap that you need to put on.
- Initiation.
- For a picture.
I'm not sure gentlemen at the back
will be too happy with this,
but, there we go.(laughs)
Excellent. (laughs)
- She likes the elbow bump.
- She does, excellent. (laughs)
- It was lovely today.
- Yes, right this way.
- Thank you.(applauding)
- Thank you very much.
(soft music)